alors les beaux lots devra prendre une
grosse branlée dit pareil savez sur une
faute sur le gardien exponentielle mais
c'est quoi ça je sais moi c'était avant
qu'il fallait penser à réviser
[Musique]
le bac cette année c'est mon point tu
les retrouves racontera d'une autre
descente pardon
je vais te démonter camps illégaux et je
vais terminer comme un kebab si loin des
pas réceptifs à la méthode douce je
pensais de lui mettre un bon coup de
pression et avions petits que j'ai pas
envie de me faire enfiler dans les deux
banques à savoir ce que tu as peur tu as
parfois mecs faut que je raconte un truc
de ouf on va braquer les sujets du bac
[Musique]
non